mari says any suggestions for
transitioning this is a Freudian slip
here but I like it transitioning out of
a deadbeat career I think you mean
dead-end career hari
but deadbeat career so so I I think that
is I think you couple that question was
sort of Kate's question and in fact if I
were to add anything to Kate's question
I sometimes figure out what is enough
because sometimes I learned this also in
the corporate world I took a step back
toward the very end because I realized I
got this promotion that I didn't even
want but I everyone said well you'd be
stupid if you didn't take this promotion
you'd be stupid if you didn't but would
I be smart if I did right that's good
and and actually no I was I was stupid
either way it was just more stupid to
take the to take the promotion and I
think we very rarely ask ourselves what
is enough Ryan and I did this experiment
recently with all of our patreon thank
you to everyone who supports some
patreon we decide to hey 6000 patreon
members is enough it's enough to pay
podcast Sean and Jessica andrews on
social media and Jordan know more over
here
who does our our filmmaking and also it
pays me in Ryan's a little bit of money
but we rarely asked like what is enough
it's always more like yeah I want to
sell three million books it's like well
why is it so you can build wells in
Africa know it so I could solve says
sold three million books yeah wait a
minute what what does that even mean and
right and so like what is enough and so
whether it's Kate or Hari maybe identify
what you're enough is mm-hmm
so you know where you're transitioning
to dude so for Hari the this is where
minimalism really came in for me and
Josh is you know I was stuck in this rut
of lake well you know I make like you
know 150 thousand bucks a year and I
spend every dime of it in fact I was in
debt and I got to pay this car payment I
got to pay this this house payment I got
to pay off this credit card debt and
well I just I have to keep this job
because I got all this going and it's
like no no sell your car
sell your house
get rid of as much debt as possible so
you don't have to make that much money
if hurry if you want to change your
employment you need to change right now
what you are what were your finances are
going we first and foremost because I'm
assuming Hari is stuck because he's got
to pay his bills he has to keep this job
in order to keep his lifestyle going so
for me and for Josh I mean that's where
minimalism helped us to get unstuck it's
what helped us get out of those dead-end
jobs it was being able to take a step
back so we could take some steps forward
in a new direction that we wanted to go
you